-Welcome back, we're hanging out
with Idris Elba.
Look at the -- come on.
Who else does that?
Who else --
You're the greatest.
And in honor of your new movie,
"The Harder They Fall,"
we're about to play
a brand new game.
This is called
The Fastest Card in the West.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Idris, in front of each of us,
you have a stack of cards
with random phrases
like "hamburger helper"
or "we are the champions."
On the screen,
we're going to say a category
like, "a bad thing
to whisper
to your spouse before bedtime."
Then as fast as you can
and it has to be really fast,
you have to choose
which of your cards
best fits in that category.
We're going to show our cards
to the audience
and whoever gets the most
applause wins the round.
Sound good?
-Sounds good. Let's do it.
-Alright, here we go.
The first category is
the Halloween party
was completely ruined by blank.
Alright, all done. Okay.
I think I got one.
"Half-priced sushi."
I put.
"A pool party at Tim McGraw's
house."
It wasn't bad. Alright,
so Idris takes round one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-Yeah. You took it.
You definitely took it,
half-priced sushi.
I didn't have that card.
Alright.
Our next category
is everybody loves.
Okay. Ready?
Oh.
I put "A double-decker bus tour
of downtown Cincinnati."
-I think that's two.
I think that's two.
-That's true, yeah.
I think I got the I got
the point of that one, right?
Yeah. Good.
Alright, here we go.
Next category is Jeff Bezos is
going to SpaceX to escape blank.
Mm? Mm, mm! Okay.
-You ready?
-Yeah.
-Do I go first?
-You go first this time.
-"Yellow Starburst."
No one likes yellow Starburst.
Oh, my God. Come on!
You knew you're
going to win that one, man!
You're confident.
You're so confident.
Darn it.
-It was a good card!
-Yeah, you knew you had it.
-It was a great card.
I don't have that in my pile.
-Alright.
Our next round
in our category is
what I want written
on my tombstone.
-Oh, man. Ah, you're going
to win this one.
-I think I'm going to win.
Alright, ready?
You go first. You go first.
-Yeah.
-"Wearing sweatpants
every single day."
What do I want
written on my tombstone?
"Fun Size."
-You get that one.
-I know, I knew I'd get that.
Okay, look, it's a tie game.
It's time for the final round.
This one is worth
a thousand points.
Whoever wins this
with the whole thing ready?
Here's the final category
finish this song lyric
Money, money, money --
I'm hanging with my honey,
I know it's never funny,
cuz I got.
-Okay.
-You go first, bud.
-Ooh!
Money, money, money,
I'm hanging with my honey,
I know it's not funny,
cuz I got --
Idris Elba. Yeah, I knew I got
that one!
I knew I got that one, Bud!
But thanks to my man
we always love seeing you, man.
Idris Elba.
-Love seeing you, man.
-His new movie, "The Harder
They Fall" is in theaters now.
Coming to Netflix
on November 3rd.